hello everyone and welcome to the
langfocus channel my name is paul today
i am going to talk about the spanish
language as you may know spain has more
than one language so when i say spanish
i'm referring specifically to castilian
spanish which is spoken as a native
language by 74 of the people of spain
and 99 of the people of spain including
second language speakers castilian is
the spanish language that grew to become
one of the most important global
languages during this video i might
refer to it as castilian to contrast it
with other languages of spain but
usually i'll refer to it as spanish out
of all languages in the world spanish
has the second largest number of native
speakers with 470 million native
speakers as well as another 90 million
who speak it as a second language it is
also one of the most widely dispersed
languages with 44 countries of the world
having at least 3 million native
speakers of spanish or more it is one of
the six official languages of the un as
well as an official language of the
european union it is also an official
language of 21 countries if we include
puerto rico which is a territory of the
us
it also used to be an official language
of the philippines but it is not anymore
spanish is also the third most widely
used language on the internet according
to one source that i consulted the use
of spanish online has grown by 800
percent in the past few years spanish is
a member of the ibero romance sub family
of the romance language family other
members of that subfamily include
portuguese galician and some people say
catalan like all romance languages
spanish developed from vulgar latin the
spoken latin that was brought to the
area by the roman empire vulgar latin
evolved into numerous regional dialects
which eventually became distinct enough
to be considered different languages
there are documents from the 9th century
that are written in an early form of
castilian spanish or we could say a late
form of vulgar latin in any case
documents like these show that the
vulgar latin dialects were becoming
separate languages by that point
castilian spanish is the language that
arose in the north central region of the
iberian peninsula called castile and it
grew more and more distinct from its
neighbor language leonis it became
firmly established as a distinct
language in the 13th century when king
alfonso decided to standardize the
written language for official use based
on the dialect spoken in toledo a
process which continued for a few
hundred years until the 16th century in
the 1300s the southern part of the
iberian peninsula was under the control
of al-andalus a muslim-controlled
territory that had previously controlled
most of the peninsula the reconquista
which means the reconquest resulted in
the retaking of the muslim areas and of
the spread of castilian spanish to the
south there it was influenced by the
most arabic dialects those were romance
dialects spoken by muslims in al-andalus
that contained a lot of loan words from
arabic castilian spanish absorbed a lot
of those arabic loanwords up to four
thousand words or eight percent of the
modern language's vocabulary some common
spanish words of arabic origin are asta
which means until that comes from the
arabic word hatta with the same meaning
which means i hope comes from the arabic
word lausa or inshallah which means if
it's god's will asette which means oil
as in olive oil comes from the arabic
word azeit with the same meaning there
are also a lot of words in spanish that
begin with a l al which is the arabic
definite article for example al kol from
the arabic word al-kahul which of course
means alcohol and alcalde which means
mayor comes from the arabic word
al-qaeda which means judge in arabic
that's just a couple examples but there
are lots of words beginning with al in
spanish the christian reconquest of the
south successfully ended in 1492 and
that very same year spain began sending
explorers like christopher columbus
abroad to build the spanish empire the
spanish language spread along with the
empire to the americas to the spanish
east indies which includes present-day
philippines and to some parts of africa
one area it spread to was mexico which
today has the largest spanish-speaking
population of any country with 120
million speakers of spanish the variety
of spanish spoken in mexico varies
somewhat from the variety spoken in
spain and that's true for the other
spanish-speaking countries as well the
standard written language is basically
the same everywhere but the spoken
language has some differences especially
in pronunciation and in vocabulary and
especially in common daily vocabulary
like clothing food and things like that
in latin america various native
languages influence the different local
varieties of spanish what's the best
variety of spanish to learn well the
varieties are often categorized into
european spanish and latin american
spanish from what i understand there
isn't a lot of difference for beginners
no matter which variety you learn you
will be able to adapt to other varieties
quite easily
personally i've met more spanish
speakers from mexico than from any other
country so for me that's the natural
choice but for you it depends on which
variety you are most likely to use and
which one you're most interested in
like romance languages in general
spanish shares a lot of vocabulary with
english not identical vocabulary but
related vocabulary that you can figure
out and you can more easily remember if
you associate it with the related
english words let's take a look at a
couple sentences cuanto questa un viaje
a nueva york
okay so the first word quanto that
sounds to me like quantity so i think it
means how much because this is a
question
the next word questa well i think that
probably means cost the next word un i
know that means ah the indefinite
article the next word viaje well that
looks like voyage to me or voyage in
french so i think it means a voyage or a
trip
and then ah i know means two and nueva
york of course that means new york so i
think this means how much does a trip to
new york cost if we translate it
literally how much cost a trip to new
york
another sentence el umbre conduce an
automobile so let's look at it word by
word el i know that means the definite
article hombre that's a word i know from
movies and stuff i think that means man
well i'm not sure let's come back to
that one in a second
and automobile that means automobile car
so go back to conduce well maybe that
means conduct or in this case you don't
conduct an automobile you drive an
automobile so this means the man drives
an automobile or the man drives a car so
you can see that you can figure out what
those words mean if you look at each
word and analyze them it's not always
that easy but that's an easy example so
you know what i mean and also if we look
at the syntax of those sentences we can
see that they're very similar to english
so the first sentence again cuanto
questa un viaje on nuevo york so how
much cost a trip to new york so quite
similar to english but just sort of
simplified the next sentence
the man drives a car that one is word by
word exactly the same as english so it's
translatable directly of course the
grammar gets more complicated than that
but just the most basic syntax is very
similar to english so this is one of the
benefits of learning a romance language
for english speakers according to the
american foreign service institute
spanish is a category one language that
means that relatively speaking it is one
of the easier languages for native
english speakers to learn so what are
you waiting for learn some espanol or
should i say castellano i'm not sure
because spanish speakers themselves
can't actually agree on this issue in
the red-colored countries the preferred
term is castellano and the blue colored
countries the preferred term is espanol
and in spain you can see that there is
some disagreement about which term is
best
if you're a native speaker of spanish
maybe you can tell us what you think
about that in the comments down below
and other people you can leave your
comments too thank you for watching have
a nice day
[Music]
you